we begin with breaking news out of
Israel its military says one of its
airstrikes has killed the commander of
the armed group Islamic Jihad the group
confirmed Baha Abdullah el Atta was
killed in Gaza City
Garza's Health Minister says a man and a
woman had been killed in the strike
Israel has accused the iranian-backed
Palestinian group of carrying out recent
rocket attacks inside Israel Israel has
now shut all of the Gaza border
crossings let's go live to Harry for
said in West Jerusalem how are you just
bring us up to date with these
airstrikes what more can you tell us
well we know what you've just said that
the Israeli military has claimed the
strike that has killed Baha Arthur who
they say is a senior Islamic Jihad
commander in the northern part of the
Gaza Strip and as you say they have been
blaming Islamic Jihad for the the recent
rounds of rocket attacks that have come
out of Gaza in recent months the kinds
of escalations that we've seen which
have led to Israeli retiree air strikes
and they've led Israel and Gaza towards
more and more difficult and dangerous
territory in terms of those escalations
however this in itself is potentially an
extremely dangerous escalation Israel
has not targeted leadership in this way
for some time and so this strike is I
think accepted here to be one which
brings with it significant risks
certainly in Israel South they have
closed schools for the day there have
been rockets coming out of Gaza already
rocket siren warnings have been flashing
up and this is a situation which also
feeds into an extremely tense and and
delicate political situation in Israel
Benjamin Netanyahu remains in charge of
a caretaker administration are for a
second and conclusive election within
the space of a year he's just appointing
today is the day that Nathalie Bennett a
new Defense Minister takes over Israel
says it is prepared for whatever happens
that it is preparing its military to
respond as it as is required but
certainly this is
potentially extremely serious step up in
this sort of long-running confrontation
of rockets and airstrikes that we've
been seeing for well over a year now and
Harry just briefly are we likely then to
see any response from the Palestinian
armed groups in Gaza well yes already
there have been rockets coming out the
idea of a senior commander such as this
is going to require a response drums in
particular Islamic Jihad obviously
Israel says that it's Homs Hamas
responsible for everything that comes
out of the Gaza Strip that is its policy
however it has been making a distinction
to some extent with these rockets when
when they've been fired they've been
talking about Islamic Jihad they've been
talking about potential divisions within
the armed factions inside Gaza so that
Israel has decided to target
specifically the senior Islamic Jihad
figure however I think we can expect
both some US and either the arcus and
brigades the military wing of Hamas and
Islamic Jihad to respond in force and so
we're up for another round of escalation
almost certainly alright to Harry for
set there in West Jerusalem Harry thank
you for that and in another breaking
story syrian state television is
reporting this syrian army has fired on
a quote hostile target west of the
capital damascus it's unclear what the
target was or if it was brought down
meanwhile syrian state media is also
reporting an attack near the Lebanese
embassy in the Syrian capital let's go
live now to Stephanie Becker in Beirut
Stephanie let's talk first about this
target that the Syrian military said
they fired on some reports are
suggesting it's a drone what more can
you tell us yeah it is it's unclear at
the moment so what is clear is that
there has been an explosion around the
medve area this is in the southwestern
part of the Syrian capital there are
videos and pictures being uploaded to
social media that show what appears to
be a residential building on fire there
are two different reports coming out
that either a target was hit in a
residential building as I just mentioned
or actually on the air base which is a
base used by the Syrian army it
has been struck before by Israel for
example targeting weapon shipments to
Hezbollah so at the moment it isn't
clear but it is clear that something has
been hit as you mentioned the Syrian
state news agency saying that its air
defense missile has been activated to
intercept some form of projectile in the
sky this all happened in the last hour
or so so I think we're gonna have to
wait and see as to the exact target and
what has happened but certainly it is
clear that there has been some form of
an explosion in the Syrian capital in
the last hour so yeah just ask you that
Stephanie because the syrian state media
is also reporting an attack near the
Lebanese embassy in the Syrian capital
are these two incidents related they
could be they're in a similar area
during in the southwest of the capital
of Damascus so as we know were these
things when they happen initially there
can be constructing reports about the
same incident certainly the pictures
that I've been seeing I cannot verify
showed a residential building to be on
fire there are unconfirmed report of
casualties so it's something we're going
to have to monitor again Israel targeted
on various occasions weapons shipments
it deemed that were going to Hezbollah
through Syria from Iraq this is
something that the Israelis usually
never confirm but they have mentioned
they have said in the past that this is
a red line for them this is something
that they will do again we don't know if
this was Israel we don't know what the
target was but certainly I think people
are asking whether Israel has been
extremely busy this evening certainly
have you just heard from Harry targeting
that leader of Palestinian Islamic Jihad
and within similar timing this strike in
Damascus but again I think very early to
draw any form of conclusion were still
not sure as to what exactly the target
was in huge all right I Stephanie Becker
there in the Lebanese capital Stephanie
thank you